hey how's it going bros my name is
beautiful so I asked you breasts to dis
me ha me I am perfect
but either way you brush fried and here
are the results you are as ugly as
Donald Trump say what you want about
Donald Trump but have you seen his hair
it's like an eagle came and landed there
it's beautiful thank you now I may not
share his opinion but I know a great
hair when I see one
you want a dis you want a dish you look
like an Australian slight racism there
appreciate it
dog leister odd oh I look like a
Brazilian dude yeah you got me there
Oh PewDiePie who are you why did I like
this page did I really like this or is
this spam your spam Swedish guy who
sucks dick for views equals PewDiePie
yeah what do you think all youtubers do
come on dudes you're so annoying and you
swear a lot in your videos that's a bad
influence for the children you play some
games that are so lame
I hate you peers for being more fabulous
than me
slaps PewDiePie's but bad period is that
a disc sorry appearance I really love
you yes you did get me really hard I
really you I really felt that butt slap
it really hurt your videos used to be
good now every other video is sponsored
because you suck dick and buffnut for ad
revenue well what can I say the ads are
getting smarter eat
Edgar's [ __ ] and choke on it
[ __ ] damn [ __ ] hey PewDiePie
you're cute
ah thanks [ __ ] Sweden you're mean just
kidding stop [ __ ] with my emotions
spits you're the best thing that
happened to my life probably whenever I
feel bad I just want to come running to
your videos and watch them all until all
the bad thoughts are done you are the
man of my dreams well I don't know how
you diss people in your country but
flirting with them is not it no pity pie
you ratchet ass [ __ ]
I hope you fall in a puddle with socks
oh oh no with sucks your videos make me
want to take my eyes out just like my
aunt
damn what me yeah how could you say that
did Edgar shave your beard for you
because it looks kind of like Wolverine
but they're really shitty version of
what you got a problem with how I shave
it weird you say that to my face but I'm
a [ __ ] man Bruce you are you are some
cold-ass [ __ ] all right Peter
pie just go to hell I don't know how the
hell did you get those 35 million
subscribers it's actually 41 million
well [ __ ] I think I'm gonna diss
millions but your dog Edgar sucks I know
he's the [ __ ] worst at least you
don't have to live with him goddamn it
hey are you gay no I'm not because you
suck dicks make longer videos you do
three minutes crappy videos while better
youtubers do longer and make less money
well did you know that you actually make
more money the longer the videos are so
I purposely chose to make shorter more
quality videos I make less money but
more people complain [ __ ] you you look
like a pineapple I only hang out with
apples you racist son of a B have you
considered plastic surgery by that I
mean putting a plastic bag over your
head
you look like a bisexual lesbian and
what the [ __ ] is that scary girl me me
[ __ ] [ __ ] is a bisexual focus you look
like a juicy meatball I'm pretty sure
that's a good thing thank you you look
like a potato no no it can't be
the prophecy did not for toll this can
we scan my face for potatoes car ID bros
that was all good and fun but don't be
mean unless unless you have good reason
to be me that's all for me for now thank
you both for watching and as always
being awesome and as always it is - yes
dear fellow brothers my name is
PewDiePie I've searched for centuries
a ways to perfect click baits and views